you know what i'm going to say yeah yeah
oh
jd fred give me some temp
um jd over vacation
lost his virginity to a check really
yeah you want to explain i have her on
the phone
wow yeah her name is
courtney courtney hi hi how are you and
how old are you
i'm 28. all right 20 28 how old are you
jd
i just turned 26 over to break all right
how did you come to me courtney
um she sent me a message on the myspace
on myspace.com courtney why did you send
him a message how did you know of jd
from our show
i was on myspace already for for a while
and i heard you goofing on his profile
yeah so i looked it up that day and then
um i just i sent him a message saying i
was a fan of the show or whatever and we
started talking from there
is this just a one-time thing or is this
like a relationship no it's sort of like
a
sort of long-distance type thing you
know what jd he was he was awesome when
i went down to new york
and you weren't turned off by the way he
speaks and the fact that he's like kind
of napoleon dynamite-ish and stuff
i mean i think it's so awesome that he
was so cool i was feeling really
uncomfortable in the situation i was in
and he was like come stay at my place so
you felt bad for him in a sense no no no
no
but he was awesome too this was your
return phase it was awesome to me
all right so it wasn't out of any real
attraction it was more like you wanted
to pay him back oh no we
totally clicked like i've been talking
to him for a long time all right all
right that's cool all right you like the
personality
yeah he was on the phone the other day
and put me on the phone with him i
talked to him
so do you two have phone sex no did you
talk dirty or anything did you talk to
her did he talk dirty at all courtney
you know like i said it was it was quick
the first time that night it wasn't much
time for
he went i want you to and then
you